hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys
actually know my areas so today Selena
and I are checking out a video from
filthy Frank called vomit cake why talk
more let's see what filthy Frank has to
offer us
hey welcome to the Franken kitchen what
it do [ __ ] still be Frank
protege right here I'll probably say max
for you today we're gonna make some are
all right and then we got a healthy
basic here with us
Mamma Mia yeah that's what you don't
raise good ah the back yeah and we have
most importantly honk out there yeah
[ __ ] this is broken
golly gee if only there was another way
we can mix that cake alright ladies and
gentlemen today the mixture is broken so
we're gonna use old Maxie boy here as a
as a mixer meet two cups of self-raising
flour it's that left at a young age so
let's raise itself to my new dance the
llamas vision really stone for me oh god
where yeah no no no
what do you pull so no no no do it man
I'll push you swallow oh you can never
Shout bro hey give it a Bobby's doing
here okay so we can catch all the
remains now you do love to ii agreed
mister can I please have one cup of
castor sugar please
ocean okay that's a lot of sugar
Oh Alex March on him you want the water
yep got water back down work we're about
oh yeah
I can't handle this mess gross that's
almost oven oh wow Wow
eating it prototype monies from the
master the master works from the guy
while one teaspoon of vanilla extract
that's easy
on there where knowledge of her former
Texas cuffing that she's [ __ ] it's the
next the next agreed so gross what I
could row up from just you know a Denis
on that like fun
what is happening I can't do that this
moment that she it's my mouth ah no no I
can't believe this is happening right
now
there's going to my eyes go so there's
no stop oh my god let me stop spitting
in my cake that we're relaunching no
they're gonna eat it Oh what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is back yo like a tumor cake
it's what a couple tumors don't do it
don't do it
oh thank you someone who doesn't know
honey I'm home sorry yeah forgot about a
romantic night out I got some flowers
got it from our gardener Julio
no theme frame so Chris you got some
cake today you're implicated do you want
to do all rather like just kidding we
can't afford no surely no no now you Oh
what the [ __ ] oh god I kind of really am
regretting agree to watching this with
you
Oh No please don't do it
are you with that oh my gosh
how is he eating it
I'm so sorry already here right now I
never started your day all right
stop big chunk of it no just your
mother's recipe Frank
my mom is terminal cancer - can't
believe savage you wanna kiss right now
every time I just like over my eyes
funny okay there's a minute left and
having a little bit of Islamic squabble
so this is good it's good yeah you got
one flies it is hey did you have problem
at the franca you made my feel a whole
lot of love on the inside it's full of
them
you see folks like Vickery dollar I
think we all are a little something from
leave legalized gay marriage sometimes
people are just about their outsides if
no one should be judged for their
outsides only the insides it's filthy
Frank for the [ __ ] up it's filthy Frank
yes let's get some [ __ ] tonight oh yeah
wow that just happened that is my
reality right now
oh my god don't we just watch that I
feel like throwing up right I did I
didn't have we're not gonna talk about
this video normally I go into some like
a discussion analysis [ __ ] no we're not
we're not doing that this time no we're
just moving on if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you could check out
Selena's Chandler channel color my
energy you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter I have a vine and a
periscope and oh [ __ ] I did like one
part when they were the naruto and
sasuke costume because I love Naruto
I like how free-spirited and fun and
random these guys are but you could tell
they're just having a fun time but oh my
god Oh what did I do
um I respect their Drive ambition oh you
want some breakfast yeah baby some
breakfast buddy
breakfast yeah move on to the next video